this is a fascinating segment that goes
to the limits of political loyalty
because there are some trump supporters
whose undying support for trump
has no limit but for some trump
supporters
their support of trump does have a limit
and that limit is called the coronavirus
vaccine you're going to
be probably horrified by these clips
after a year of donald trump telling his
own supporters
that the pandemic isn't serious calling
it the china virus
that you don't need a vaccine some of
those trump supporters
now don't want the vaccine they see the
vaccine as liberal nonsense
especially as they see joe biden as the
one who is so quickly
accelerating vaccination uh nearly three
million doses the last two days we'll
talk about that tomorrow but that's very
good news
so cnn sends their reporter gary tuckman
to a diner
in boise city oklahoma and it
is compelling video this county
was a 92 percent trump county back in
november
but right now we have some conflicting
numbers we know that most republican
voters still like trump
but about half of republicans don't want
the vaccine as of last week trump now
recommends to his followers
that they get the vaccine so we have a
statistical conflict
they mostly like trump who's saying get
the vaccine but half of them
don't want the vaccine how does this
conflict manifest
gary tuckman asks the diners questions
about the vaccine
it got awkward and very ignorant let's
take a look at the first clip
it's breakfast time in boise city
oklahoma
and i have this question does anybody in
this restaurant think it's a good idea
to take the vaccine
no raise your hand if you think it's a
good idea
anyone here is a good idea to take the
vaccine raise your hand if you think
it's a good idea
not one person here thinks is a good
idea
complete quiet so that's already not so
good
and then gary tuchman speaks to some
specific people and here
i would get the kids out of the room for
this this is
ugly ugly stuff that we're about to see
take a look what do you think about the
vaccine are you gonna take the vaccine
no sir
tell me why well i don't trust the
government and i don't trust biden
chad and misty hughes are husband and
wife neither of them plan to get the
vaccine
just don't want to why don't you if you
don't mind me asking
because when i take the flu shot i
usually get the flu so
there's no reason to take it are you
saying you think you'll get covered by
taking the cobra
are you why are you thinking that the
research doesn't show that at all
it shows that it keeps people safe
that's just my choice
so that first guy is bad enough who says
i don't trust the government or
biden because remember the vaccine was
developed
not because of trump but it was
developed during trump's administration
trump is taking credit for it trump's
people initially oversaw
the initial distribution which was
completely abortive but still
like the first guy doesn't care now joe
biden is president
now is when that guy could get a vaccine
and he doesn't trust the government or
joe biden
but the second guy the flu shot usually
gives me the flu
it can't happen it's impossible doesn't
happen so i will assume that the covet
vaccine will give me covet
that's not necessarily a trump biden
thing
that's total vaccine ignorance that
appears to go beyond politics although
it seems to still exist more on the
right than on the left let's look at
another one of these
absolutely horrifying clips these women
are sisters
and they too are doubters why are you
doubtful
they just started rolling them out well
yeah but they've i mean this has been a
worldwide effort
by a great deal claim that the flu can
be cured
but still hundreds of thousands of
people die from the flu well
yes a lot of people but not nearly as
much as covent this is a horrible
pandemic and this is like
an amazing vaccine these vaccines have
come out they're saving lives
no i will just agree to disagree on this
subject
i just i'm just not i'm not going to
take it she said
they claim the flu can be cured
but people still die of the flu despite
having a vaccine
so this is like it's the brain is
it's is it putty is it uh i don't know
what to call it
no one claims the flu vaccine cures flu
the idea is the flu vaccine
prevents flu in some and in others it
makes it less severe
but the flu vaccines are not nearly as
effective as these coronavirus vaccines
are
and if you wonder how does someone get
tricked by trump
into believing he's going to build a
wall and that mexico will pay for it
that'll fix trade that he'll put in a
beautiful health care plan
these are the same people that believe
the flu shot will give you the flu
right these are the people we're talking
about that fell for that stuff and were
tricked into voting for donald trump
here's another clip what if
president trump came out and was very
robust and said
take the vaccine i took it even though i
didn't tell anybody about it it was kind
of done secretly but i think you should
take it
he said it a little bit but he hasn't
been robust about it he was robust and
said take it would you
no new yorker why would we listen to him
either
did you vote for him he was the best
option
what's funny about that trump voter who
says
trump's a liberal new yorker why would i
listen to him anyway
that antipathy that came out there that
that cultural clash
the diners in oklahoma are like this guy
trump in the end is just like a rich
liberal new yorker that exists on
trump's behalf as well and what i mean
by that is
the vast majority of trump supporters as
i've said so many times
are the types of people that donald
trump spent his life
trying to stay away from so it's
fascinating stuff
but it is very disturbing to see these
clips and some of what these folks talk
about
you know it's like what's more dangerous
getting covet of the vaccine the answer
is obvious
getting covet is far more dangerous than
any side effects you would have from the
vaccine
another question is what's more
dangerous
getting the virus or being that ignorant
like what other risks to their lives
exist or are created because of the
degree of ignorance that they
exhibit during interviews like this it
is wacky wacky stuff
and you know i told the story last week
of i've spent time
in rural northern indiana and
while i don't agree with the political
views of the people there
seeing it and seeing how basically you
grow up
in a church and on a gun range that's
what there is in northern indiana
being told that guns and abortion are
the two most important things
of course you're not voting for
democrats because you're for for 18
years by the time you can vote and
longer by the time you know
you're older that's all that you that's
all that's there and that's all that
that
is your experience of course you're not
going to vote for joe biden based on
what
what is publicly said we have to
understand these folks
because as ignorant as they are if they
don't get vaccinated it's bad for all of
us
and um unfortunately the the sort of
ignorance is bliss type of thing
it may work for them but it's still
dangerous for many others so interesting
interesting segment there gary tuckman
with cnn
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress
at home and it's just the perfect
mattress one of the best things about
helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have
and they will pair you with a mattress
that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed
i often get too hot at night the
mattress keeps me cool
it's not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video